i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
respeto que limpias las playas pero no
lo admiro dijo un hombre en la que fue
nuestra última cita
no quise discutir no quise defender mi
punto ante un hombre que claramente no
comparte mi manera de pensar respecto a
nuestras responsabilidades como
habitantes de este planeta
tal vez debía hacerlo y entrar en un
debate y cerrar con broche de oro la
peor de las citas que he tenido en mi
vida
porque no lo hice entonces porque no
hable
al tomar el curso de buceo en estrés y
rescate aprendí cuatro pasos importantes
para poder salir con vida ante una
situación peligrosa bajo el mar
paso número 1
[Música]
detente
antes de perder el control o de tomar
una muy mala decisión
detente
paso número 2
una dos las veces que sean necesarios
respirar
paso número 3 piensa qué puedo hacer
para salir de esta situación en la que
me encuentro y paso número 4 actúa
estos cuatro pasos no solamente ya me
salvaron bajo el mar
intento aplicarlos todos los días y me
ayudan todos los días
imaginen la cantidad de veces que he
visto a gente tirando basura pero
conflicto genera más conflicto
violencia genera más violencia y a veces
el silencio a veces es la mejor
respuesta
a lo largo de mis años intentando
proteger al planeta he pasado por todas
las reacciones por todas hasta que
finalmente aprendí que la mejor es la
amorosa a veces hasta la coqueta
pero sobre todo la que predica con el
ejemplo
en diciembre del 2011 viaje a cancún
para compartir con estudiantes mis
aventuras y mis experiencias en áfrica
como camarógrafo estuve solamente día y
medio y no quería irme sin antes haber
visto el famosísimo mar turquesa de
cancún le rogué a un amigo que por favor
me llevara me llevó a playa delfines
para que me metiera yo 10 minutos al mar
al salir del agua le dije que por favor
me tomar una fotografía
esta fue la primera de muchas imágenes
así tome muy en serio remover los
tóxicos que lastiman a nuestros mares a
pesar de vivir a cientos de kilómetros
de las costas
los seres humanos tenemos la capacidad
de hacer a un lado todo aquello que nos
hace daño
los animales no
una tortuga no puede distinguir la
diferencia entre una bolsa de plástico y
una medusa
una ballena no se puede liberar de
inmensas redes de pesca así como
nosotros nos liberamos de un pantalón
apretado
gracias a las redes sociales nos
enteramos de las cientas de especies que
aparecen en costas del mundo sin vida
y con los estómagos llenos de basura
[Música]
reaccionamos
comentamos compartimos
pero será suficiente
no para mí no es suficiente es urgente
hacer algo más estemos donde estemos
lejos o cerca de las costas todos
estamos conectados todos respiramos el
mismo aire caminamos por la misma tierra
así lo vídeo así lo veo acá y mi
queridísimo amigo que hay de alemania
calle en febrero del año pasado me
invita a una limpieza de playa en playa
del carmen y después de esta limpieza
unimos fuerzas durante 11 meses
cansada de estar hablando tanto de las
bolsas de plástico y de los potes llegué
a esta limpieza con una cubeta decidida
a levantar colillas de cigarro y me puse
la meta de levantar 500
al final de la jornada de dos horas
solamente logramos llenar esa cubeta con
más de 3500 colillas de cigarro
gracias a la europa
un guardavidas que nos vio pasar nos
donó sus colillas que él mismo levantó
durante seis meses en la playa del hotel
donde trabaja
la reacción de la gente al vernos pasar
es sin duda una de mis partes favoritas
en las limpiezas de playa
gente que nos aplaude nos dan las
gracias otros se levantan nos ayudan
otros nos preguntan quién les paga
de qué asociación son
hola mi favorita son del gobierno
pero también las hay amargas en cancún
estaba yo muy feliz levantando mis
colillas de cigarro cuando de pronto se
acerca a mí una chica completamente
alcoholizada me insulta y patear la
cubeta
cuál fue mi reacción
detente
piezas piensa cada vida
y actuar
fui por mi cubeta y empezar a levantar
las colillas otra vez qué hubiera pasado
si me pongo a pelear con una borracha
violencia genera violencia insisto y esa
violencia la contagiamos a los seres que
nos rodean la transferimos al planeta
maltratamos a los animales
destruimos nuestro entorno tiramos
basura
y seres humanos con un sentido de
empatía por el planeta es lo que más
necesitamos más ahora que nunca
y como comenzamos entonces
por nosotros mismos tenemos que dejar de
pelear de discutir de intoxicar a
nuestra alma y al planeta con más
tóxicos dejar de atentar contra el
bienestar de nuestro cuerpo de
destruirnos a nosotros mismos como con
el cigarro
sabemos que el cigarro nos provoca
cáncer de tráquea de pulmones de boca y
aún así seguimos sumando
porque porque nos estamos haciendo esto
porque por dos minutos de placer estamos
sacrificando a nuestro cuerpo y no sólo
eso le estamos dando también en la torre
al planeta
son pocos los fumadores que al
terminarse su cigarro ponen la colilla
en un bote de basura o en un cenicero
una
una colilla una solamente contamina 50
litros de agua dulce y 8 litros de agua
salada
en febrero del año pasado comenzamos a
levantar las colillas y para febrero de
este año logramos levantar 44 mil 34
colillas de cigarro con la ayuda de
aproximadamente 700 voluntarios entre
las limpiezas de cancún y playa del
carmen
esto quiere decir que en un promedio de
46 horas evitamos que 372.000 perdón 52
mil 272 litros de agua salada y 2
millones 201 mil 700 litros de agua
dulce fueran contaminados por este
tóxico
para que nos imaginemos más gráficamente
estos números con dos millones
doscientos mil 700 litros de agua dulce
podemos llenar 110.000 ochenta y cinco
garrafones de 20 litros y con 352 mil
272 litros de agua salada podemos llenar
17.613 litros 20 litros
la razón es de 20 litros
y no sólo eso nos pusimos a la tarea de
a ver cuánto dinero hay en estas
colillas de cigarro en este año
levantamos 121 mil 93 pesos con 50
centavos en colillas de cigarro
las colillas de cigarro es sin duda el
residuo que más levantamos en todas
nuestras limpiezas y no solamente las de
playa del carmen y cancún a nivel
mundial si cada año se producen 5.6
trillones de cigarros imaginen la
cantidad de colillas tiradas en nuestro
planeta el planeta está fumando
estamos exagerando los ambientalistas
porque tanto escándalo
no una colilla de cigarro está compuesta
de acetato de celulosa un tipo de
plástico que tarda hasta 10 años en
degradarse y que además contienen los
tóxicos que se desechan al producir los
cigarros están formando fungicidas
insecticidas
hasta veneno para roedores
entonces qué hacemos con todas estas
colillas
afortunadamente encontré a una empresa
mexicana que se dedica a convertir estas
colillas de cigarro en estás
hermosísimas macetas para cactáceas y
suculentas haber encontrado a esta
empresa ha sido las series en el pastel
porque el lugar al que voy no dejó de
ver colillas tiradas en el suelo no dejo
de ver a este fumador disfrutando de su
cigarro antes de lanzarlo a la calle una
tarde por ejemplo justamente iba yo a
entregar colillas de cigarro para que
fueran transformadas en mi bici cuando
llama mi atención un chico en una
motoneta no solamente me llamó la
atención por guapo me llamó la atención
porque vi como yo lanzó la colilla del
cigarro porque no prendida
cuál fue mi reacción
me detuve levanté la colilla la coloqué
en la cubeta y mientras me alejaba de él
no deje de escucharlo pidiéndome perdón
no le dije absolutamente nada
ahora espero que ese chico antes de
aventar la colilla piense dos veces
y así como el hay millones de fumadores
en nuestro planeta que no pueden evitar
hacer este movimiento es natural
cómo cambiarlo he hablado con algunos y
creo que si podemos lograr este cambio
en españa por ejemplo hay un grupo que
se llama no más colillas en el suelo
este grupo nació en barcelona y se ha
extendido a muchos países incluido
méxico y luego de una llamada virtual
con su fundador decidí sumarme a su
siguiente campaña
la montaña de la vergüenza
en esta imagen en particular hay 10 mil
498 colillas de cigarro que levantamos
solamente en una jornada de 2 horas 65
voluntarios en dos cuadras de playa y de
la quinta avenida
la idea es formar la montaña de la
vergüenza con colillas de cigarro y de
manera simultánea lanzarla en muchos
países entre ellos polonia españa
ecuador y méxico
creen que funcione ayudará a esta
montaña de la vergüenza
en playa del carmen tengo a niños y
jóvenes ayudándome a levantar colillas
de las calles y de las playas
en mexicalli tijuana también se han
sumado en nosotros
estamos uniendo esfuerzos trabajando en
equipo entendamos por favor que ayudar
al planeta es ayudarnos a nosotros
mismos que amar al planeta es amarnos a
nosotros mismos y que si le dedicamos
dos minutos o dos horas a limpiar
nuestras playas nuestros mares nuestras
calles nuestras selvas nuestras junglas
es dedicarnos tiempo a nosotros mismos
pero sobre todo
quiero que cambiemos nuestros hábitos
porque a pesar de que me apasiona
limpiar playas que llena de sentido mi
existencia en este planeta es algo que
quiero que disminuya quiero que
disminuya nuestra consumo exagerado esas
ganas de comprar todo de tenerlo todo
cambiar nuestros hábitos dejar de
utilizar el plástico
por ejemplo comprar fruta pelada y
envuelta en plástico y el unicel para
ahorrarnos unos minutos de nuestro día
pero sobre todo sobre todo dejar de
violentar a nuestro planeta tirando
basura
no limpio playas
porque busco el respeto y admiración de
alguien
limpio playas porque respeto admiro pero
sobre todo amo con todas las fuerzas de
mi ser a nuestro maravilloso planeta
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]